pure sunshine it's an endless natural
resource which Morocco aims to exploit
the ambitious north african kingdom
plans to construct the biggest solar
power plant in the world morocco is
going sustainable when it comes to
energy by 2020 it wants renewables to
supply forty percent of its needs german
companies also hope to benefit germany's
KfW development bank has put up 800
million euros for green Moroccan power
projects companies like Siemens are
supplying the equipment the world
climate conference meets in Marrakech in
November as the worst drought in decades
scorches Morocco the country's crucial
agriculture sector is struggling that's
why economic growth this year is only
expected to reach around 2.3 percent
recent years have seen much better
results Morocco's agricultural exports
generate revenues and create jobs the
government wants to invest millions
expanding and modernizing the industry
it's hoped that will create one and a
half million jobs in that sector alone